the world has completely turned upside
down under our pathetic excuse for a
president who doesn't know what day of
the week it is none other than America's
hostile enemies now they have no fear or
respect for Joe Biden not China not Iran
and definitely not Russia now Putin's
thugs as we talked about last night they
took down a U.S Reaper drone over
international waters which in most cases
most presidents would view as an act of
War there would be some military
response what did Biden do in response
pretty much nothing actually worse than
nothing the White House started to make
excuses for Putin's Putin's risky
Behavior they called it an accident
really anyone here believe it it's an
accident
now probably was they said it's probably
unintentional they said it probably was
a result of a profounding competence of
these Russian Pilots does anybody here
believe that they're a incompetent
fighter jet Pilots that not once but
twice the jet fuel on top of our drone
uh and then took it out of the sky I
don't believe that anyway the Biden
Administration they are lying to you the
American people and Putin's Pilots as I
said dumped multiple times uh fuel on
the Drone and then they ran the
propeller by accident was supposed to
believe I don't think so odds are 99.9
percent that Vladimir himself ordered
this to happen in fact breaking tonight
even from fake News NBC quote Russian
leadership approved aggressive actions
of jets that damaged the U.S drone
obviously Biden's Administration you
know their first instinct as to what to
always lie oh the borders not secure
because Donald Trump uh just the
opposite now get this Russia is now
attempting to retrieve our drone from
the Black Sea that they took out of the
sky before our Navy can get to it where
is the pushback Joe where are you you're
the commander-in-chief where is American
leadership why are you going to take
this not a single word from our
part-time president well frankly the
Cowardly Joe Biden now back here at home
more insanity this week's middle class
taxpayers well you're all forced to bail
out some of the richest people in the
world I call it Biden's billionaire Bank
bailout Tech CEOs people that have
Vineyards that are very rich out in Napa
California's fanciful Governor Gavin
Newsom he has three Vineyards other
Millionaires and billionaires from
Northern California were made whole by
the Biden Administration after what is
the collapse of the Silicon Valley bank
now SV b b was California's woke trendy
bank so naturally instead of
safeguarding every penny deposited svb
diverted a massive amount of money to
left-wing causes now get this this is
what we we have discovered that includes
a whopping 73 million dollars to BLM
related groups five billion dollars in
commitments to climate change and
internally the bank's obsessive you know
obsession with diversity and equity and
inclusion that took precedence over risk
management as a matter of fact on their
board there was one person that had any
real experience in banking now svb was
set up as a safe space for its employees
they hosted a month-long celebration and
implemented racial quotas svb had
absolutely no Chief risk officer for a
whopping eight months as the bank was in
the process of imploding you know get
woke go broke is is not just a slogan
when you trade logic and Merit for
radical Marxism victimhood everybody
loses except of course the billionaires
that Joe Biden has bailed out here does
anyone in this audience think these
billionaires deserve a bailout
you know everybody knows the FDIC
protects up to what 250 000 so if you
have more than 250 000 why should the
taxpayers of this country have to bail
you out and then why we lied to by Joe
Biden who said oh the taxpayers aren't
going to pay no but we're just going to
increase Bank fees well most Americans
have a bank account and they're going to
end up paying this big massive Bill to
billionaires now we see this all over
California similar to every frankly
socialist hellhole around the world you
have wealthy well-connected California's
well they have great lives they're not
impacted by the High Cost of Living
they're not impacted by Biden inflation
they're not impacted by no bail laws
defund and dismantle the police they
live in their walled mansions with armed
guards they have plenty of money banked
away and deep connections inside of
their government to protect that money
so they don't really care about high
taxes or expensive social programs it
doesn't affect them them but the middle
class in this country hard-working
Americans that get up every day work
hard play by the rules pay their taxes
raise their kids obey the laws and small
business owners you are bearing the
brunt of this burden and now the wokest
city in California San Francisco they're
now reaching the peak of insanity and
city leaders there are now seriously
considering a plan to pay each and every
African-American resident five million
dollars a piece for reparations now this
plan could cost nearly one trillion
dollars in money that San Francisco
doesn't have in fact the entire State of
California is going broke less than two
years after Biden's Blue State bailout
Newsome is already in a hole again this
time California's budget deficit is at a
whopping 24 billion dollars so is Joe
Biden going to bail them out once again
probably with your money now in the new
Democratic party the Socialist Party the
Marxist party well you can drive your
state into the ground you can release
violent criminals onto the streets you
can vilify police and First Responders
but just don't use the wrong pronoun or
the wrong word or you're going to be
labeled a racist and sexist and worse
now no one is safe from the left word
police not even our friend Whoopi
Goldberg over at the view that
hard-hitting news show take a look we
still believe that he got you know Egypt
somehow
and the election will still believe that
he cared enough about his wife to
pay the that was gas
you know when you're a certain age you
use words that you know from when you're
a kid or you remember saying and that's
what I did today and I shouldn't have
I should have thought about it a little
longer before I said it but I didn't and
I should have said cheated and I used
another word and I'm really really sorry
all right I've known Whoopi for years
whoopee stop apologizing are you tired
of apologizing you know I'm not really
sure how anyone on the left can even
navigate the complicated ever-changing
Maze of victimhood and wrong words that
we can no longer use I don't think she
had a negative intention uh when she
used the word that was so offensive to
people as I said at the top we're living
in an upside down world everybody should
be concerned hey Sean Hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to Fox News
YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else